Woo!
Hit it!
Hit--
[thud]
[rattling]
[laughter]
ERIC LADIN: When you step into
a team for the first time,
they're clocking you to
see what they can trust.
You're rolling
with [inaudible] now.
ERIC LADIN: You're
clocking them,
because what we're asked to do
is a matter of life and death.
My name is Eric Ladin.
I play Trevor Wozniak.
There's only one kill I have.
I don't need a
picture, remember?
Yeah.
Which one?
My first.
I remember every line
on the guy's face.
ERIC LADIN: Like any of these
guys, Trevor sees things,
does things that he has to
find a way to deal with.
And so he uses ink.
These guys right here?
All the past 10.
You keep track.
Oh, come on.
Like you don't?
ERIC LADIN: He knows what each
one of those skulls represent.
I think Trevor fits
in great in the sense
that he's an operator.
[gunfire]
Whether or not they agree with
his point of view on things--
TREVOR: Indian country.
What the hell are
you talking about now?
I'm talking about Truman, man.
--that's a different thing.
They're the guys.
They're loyal.
But me, I see things clearly.
ERIC LADIN: He crosses
the line a little bit
to see how somebody
else is going to react.
I remember you
from [inaudible]..
Oh, yeah, you're
the terrorist SEAL.
ERIC LADIN: And so he
messes with Fishbait.
Islam is just compatible
with life, liberty,
and the pursuit of happiness.
Do I think Trevor believes
many of the things he says?
Absolutely.
If I tattooed you with
every guy I've killed,
I'd run out of skin.
ERIC LADIN: But do I think he
says it in a way to see if he
can get a rise out of Fish?
For sure.
You got, uh, any theories
on my kind you want to add?
No, man.
I love brown people.
Come on!
I think he's testing
people's mental strength.
At the end of the day,
the men in that room
need to be most confident
about you as an operator
when you step out.
[gunfire]
[grunt]
And there's no question
that Trevor's an operator.
Might as well see
what happens next.